Hadas Bergman, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm good.
Thank you for having me, Michael.
So, you're calling from Tel Aviv
but you're actually based in Boston now.
You said you left your husband
in Cambridge.
I did.
So I just finished my first year
at Harvard Business School,
and we both live
in Harvard Square in Cambridge.
And I really wanted to see my family.
Finished my summer internship.
Packed my bags.
And came to Israel for a month.
I'm actually in 14 days
state mandated quarantine.
So, I've actually not left this house
in 13 days.
Tomorrow I'm going free.
You literally haven't even left
to go downstairs just to breath fresh air?
No.
And you're still sane?
I'm trying to be.
...
I love it. Okay. Hadas, I'm really excited
to hear about your journey,
and I'm particularly excited to focus on
the different transitions you've made
that are not very common for people
that come out
of the path that we did.
So both of us served in the 8200 unit,
but you actually took
an interesting path from there.
I know you worked at Matrix
on data and then product,
but then you transitioned into consulting
which is something irregular
for a lot of the techies
that come out of 8200.
And now, obviously,
you're in Harvard Business School
which I think is a story
worth telling on its own
the application process
and how the first year was.
So Hadas, take me back
to your days in 8200.
You're finishing the unit,
and you're transitioning
into sort of the real world.
Why consulting?
Why do you go that path?
So that's an excellent question.
So, I felt like I started
going down the path
that a lot of people
who served with us did
which was doing 8200
and then doing university.
And I worked for a startup
for almost three years.
I was one of the first employees.
Russell Rothstein, yeah.
Yes. And I really liked
the kind of entrepreneurship
startup ecosystem in Israel,
but I realized that if I planned
to be in this community in the future,
it would actually be more powerful for me
to understand how big businesses
and big corporates and governments work.
So, I really felt like
I needed to complete my tool kit
with more strategic thinking
and strategic operations
of large organization.
So I went to, I started basically
recruiting for consulting.
Nobody knew what it was.
In the US, I feel like everybody knows
what consulting is.
Right. Exactly. It's like a go to path
for so many in the US.
But in Israel, you don't even
speak about it.
When you're friend
graduates from the unit,
you never ask them,
"Hey, are you gonna think
about going into consulting?"
Right?
It's not even an option.
Yeah.
It was definitely a path less traveled
for kind of the people we hang out with usually.
But I actually sort of fell in love with it.
I spent about four years at TASC,
which is basically a Tel Aviv based
strategic consulting firm
which works with
the largest organization in Israel.
Banks, telecom companies,
a lot of work with government.
And as I started working in consulting,
I started understanding
how interesting it is
to realize what challenges
large corporates are having
and actually see from their perspective
the disruption that is happening
to their industries by startups.
So by working with a bank
or working with other type of
like big institutes and seeing
what's coming up their way
and the way they cope with it
and the way they treat it
was very interesting.
And also seeing
how they incorporate technology
into what they're doing.
So, give me your two cents
about your time spent at TASC.
What was consulting for you?
And what value did you bring
these big corporates?
Whether it was helping them
integrate with technology
or helping them understand
global issues better.
What was the real added value there?
So, the company I worked for
did not have a digital practice,
so a practice that helped businesses
with their digital transformation journey
and with incorporating technology.
So basically,
I helped the company establish a practice
that was for digital transformation
and hire people that are doing product,
that are doing data,
that are doing user interfaces
which did not exist
in a traditional consulting firm.
And I think one of the things
I'm really proud of is that
I worked a lot
with the Israeli government
and specifically
the Digital Israel Bureau
which is in charge
of digital transformation
of Israel as a whole.
And I helped them work
on the national digital strategy
for Israel, which was approved
by government resolution
at one billion ... shekels.
And then doing projects
for the Ministry of Agriculture,
Ministry of Environmental Protection,
Ministry of Justice,
about how do they take
what they currently do
and how do they do it
in the digital world.
And it was a great journey to do
with really great people
who care about the citizens.
That's amazing.
And how long did you spend at TASC?
About four years.
So Hadas, now you're at a junction,
because you've done
your 8200 intelligence unit route.
You've done the data and product route
at IT Central and Matrix, etc.
And then you've done
your four years at consulting.
And now you have to decide
what do I do next.
And what you do is you go online
and you write 10 essays
to apply for Harvard Business School
and many more tests that are even harder
than the essays.
Why?
Why go to business school
after all those years?
You've had a lot of experience,
and you're much older than I think
than the average person, I guess,
who would apply.
Maybe I'm wrong.
But you've had so much experience already
in the workforce.
And you're deciding, yes,
to go back to school, put those on hold,
and to go and enrich yourself again.
Why do you do that?
So, just as you said, to enrich myself.
I felt that the experience I had
was very Israeli focused.
The consulting company I worked for
only dealt with, or almost
only dealt with, Israeli companies.
And I felt I was missing
the global perspective in it.
In the end, we live in a global world,
and I felt like
I didn't have that experience.
I didn't know enough people from the US
or from all the different countries.
I did not know how corporates
or how ecosystems look
in different markets.
And another reason I wanted to do that
is because an area
that I'm really passionate about
is the area of digital health
or health care tech,
which I think has a lot of potential
of improving the health care
of, well basically all of us,
you and me included.
So, I thought that business school
would be a good place to also learn
and kind of get into a new ...
and make this transition.
So it all fit in,
but it was definitely challenging.
It has high opportunity costs
of the time you lose
by doing two years of business school.
Financial cost.
I had to,
me and my husband got married,
went on our honeymoon in Tanzania,
and moved to a new country.
He's never been to the US.
It's been challenging.
But what is life without challenge.
I love that.
Okay. But I want to go back because so many people,
I mean everybody knows
about Harvard Business School
and so many people talk about it.
Very few people are actually there
and few people also apply to get there.
And I'd love for you
to give me a little bit of an overview
about this application process,
especially for our friends in Israel
who don't necessarily really know
what it's like to apply
to a university in the US.
I know that when I came to Stanford,
I got bombarded with questions.
Wow. You applied to a university in the US.
You went through the whole process.
You actually got in.
It feels like it's like this long shot
that because we're so far away,
when I don't really think that it is.
But I want to hear from you.
What is tangibly the experience
and what things can our friends
back in Israel can think about
as they're considering this path?
So, first of all, you need to be
in a different mindset.
In Israel, you're used to that,
basically, you sending your scores
and you get in, right?
When you apply to business school,
they care about who you are as a person.
They want to hear your personal story
and your personal path.
They want to hear about
your success story.
very different things.
So, the journey to get
into business school
requires obviously the standardized test
where you have to do,
most people do the GMAT test
and the TOEFL, which you need to get
really high scores at.
So that's the minimum.
And then you need to do
a lot of different essays.
You need to re-do your entire resume
because Israeli resume basically
is a grocery list
of your responsibilities
whereas applying to places in the US,
and especially business school,
is about your achievements
and what makes you better
than your peers.
So, going into that mindset
of not being humble
but not being too braggy,
is something that is really hard
to transition.
And then finding a way
to tell your personal story
in a way that would be interesting
for somebody who reads it,
that would make somebody exciting
about having you there,
is not something
that I think, as Israelis, we're used to.
We don't write cover letters.
We don't write essays to get into places.
I personally also worked
with a consulting firm
that just helps people with applications.
I don't mind saying it.
I work for consulting,
so I valued having somebody on my side
who can read what I'm writing and be like,
"This is not bold enough.
You can do better."
100%.
Well, two things come to mind
when you say it.
First of all,
what you said in the beginning,
and I think it's important
not to overlook it,
this idea that the SAT and GMAT
and your grades are the minimum.
They're like the foundation
on which these universities are looking
at your application and saying,
"Is this a candidate that will be able
to finish the material in the curriculum?"
So, if they got a good SAT and
they got a good GMAT
and they got good grades
in their undergraduate or high school,
then it's likely a good indication
that they're hardworking
and that they'll be able
to simply sit in the class and work.
But then what you're mentioning is that
they're looking for this extra material
about your personality and who you are,
what is your edge,
that will actually help you
make a positive impact on the community.
And I know that when I sat down
for coffee with my admission supervisor,
who at the end decided
on my journey to Stanford,
he mentioned that
one of the most important things for them
is this idea of community.
How can we rest assured
that every person who comes in
will have a positive impact
on the community?
Because they said it's very easy
to get to fill the whole class
with valedictorians,
but that's not the goal.
And I think that
I want to hear a little bit about
the specifically the HBS experience.
What was it like
to be there this first year?
So, just saying, you are absolutely right.
They care about the cohort so much
to make sure it's diversified.
That you have interesting people.
That you have people that are passionate
about what they do.
So, definitely right.
About my first year,
I'm gonna focus on the pre-covid part
if you don't mind.
Of course.
The experience was great.
It was so different than
what university is like in Israel,
because 100% of what we studied
was the case method.
So if somebody doesn't know.
The case method, basically,
instead of theoretically learning
something new, you get a case study
about a protagonist or a company
that is going through
a specific process
that can relate to launching a new product
or changing their ... method
or doing something specific.
And then you learn the concept,
the business concept you need
to learn, through the case.
So the entire learning method
was different.
We have 940 people in my cohort,
in my year.
They put us in 10 sections.
So, my section had 94 people.
And they try to make the composite
of each section
the same as the large ones.
So 42% women,
the same percentage of minorities,
same percentage of internationals
in each class.
So you're literally in a microcosm
of the bigger Harvard Business School,
but you're getting
a tiny Harvard Business School
which is a reflection
on the greater Harvard Business School.
Exactly.
So cool.
Yeah. And then you study
with the same 94 people.
They assign you with your seat.
Basically your best friends
are gonna be the people
sitting next to you, probably.
Assigned seats in business school.
Yes.
And then for the first year,
they change your seat
after second semester,
but basically you sit in the same place.
You have your classroom.
Everybody hangs the flags
of their nationalities in the back.
And basically, you just sit
in the same place
and you have the teachers,
who are amazing professors,
just rotate through the classroom
and you stay in your seat.
It was so different
than my undergrad experience.
I went to Hebrew University.
It was just mind blowing the first week.
Give me like one of the most
remarkable case studies that you've had
because I think that, I took a few of the
Stanford Business School classes.
And when I got introduced
to this notion of case studies
where you go home at night,
you read these 20, 30 pages
of a company's journey,
and then you try to invoke from that
some lessons about,
whether it's leadership or commerce
or supply chains or whatever.
But give me a specific example
of a case study so that people
who don't know what it is
can relate to it.
I think one of my first
my favorite case study
was actually Netflix
which is a company everybody knows,
but we had a case study
about them in strategy
which was about their transition
from being a online subscription
to getting DVD by mail,
to basically being
a content online streaming.
And what I really liked is
that they basically
We had interviews with the Netflix CEO
to hear from him as the case protagonist
about why did he make this decision.
How did he decide
that he's gonna bet the company
on this new thing where nobody,
not everyone even had Internet
when he decided to do that.
So, those are the type of experiences
where you have the case protagonists
coming to the classroom
or talking via video
and kind of really being engaged in that
I think you remember so much more
from the experience
and you're much more engaged
than if you just theoretically learn
about disruption
in traditional organizations as a theme.
What is the social aspect
of the Harvard Business School like?
Is it very competitive?
Because everybody there is a rock star.
So, how is the social scene
after hours in the classroom?
So, it's very interesting
because it's not competitive at all.
Grades, we always say grades don't matter.
So you only get, in each class,
one, two or three.
You don't actually have a GPA
or any type of score.
In the end, you're either
a valedictorian or not.
That's it.
There is nothing else.
So, it's not that competitive.
And the social aspect is really fun.
So your section is kind of your family.
You have section retreats,
and section activities,
and birthday parties and baby showers
and happy hours and beer olympics.
Americans take their drinking
very very seriously.
I need two sentences about beer olympics,
because I haven't even heard of that.
So beer olympics is basically
a competition where you have two teams
that face each other.
They usually rotate
through different stations.
And they, for example, play beer pong.
They play there's a version
that's called soccer.
It's basically drinking beer
while doing things with cups and balls.
I'm not particularly good at this.
My husband really is
really really good at this.
But they take it very seriously.
Right. That far I know.
We got challenged by another section
after we had a negotiation seminar
and we kind of kicked their ass.
And they challenged us to beer olympics.
And we won.
But it was a very interesting experience.
We're all adults, right?
Harvard Business School,
the average age is like 28.
People are very serious.
And still we had a beer olympics.
I love it.
What's next on the journey then?
So consulting, products, data, IDF,
Harvard Business School.
I mean, where do you see your passion
takes you over the next,
I don't know, five or so years?
So, as I said before,
I'm really considering
and my current hypothesis is health care.
So probably post business school
would either be health care, tech,
or health care tech.
I'm still kind of trying to find
what would be the best place
right after business school,
but I think that down the line,
definitely starting
either my own or joining a great team
working on interesting health care issues
and trying to use technology and data
to solve those problems.
And having finished now the first year
of Harvard Business School,
I think that business school in general,
while the value of it
is not controversial,
but what is controversial right now
is sometimes you have companies
like Jolt in Israel who are saying,
"Well, we have an alternative to an MBA."
or they're, are at the end,
maybe going out in the real world
and doing stuff hands on
is a good also alternative to an MBA.
So, having finished that first year
and having this real world experience
in all these different sectors,
do you feel that this is something
that people who want
to grow their mindset on what are
the big global issues
and how to scale things.
Is this something really beneficial,
or is this more
for the personal experience
and to just be exposed to more things?
So I think that you can't separate both.
I think that at HBS, this cases,
So same question.
Experience versus. Go for it.
Yeah. So, I think that you can't separate
the extra-curricular experience
from the actual experience.
So coming to business school,
I moved to the US.
I got introduced into this
entirely different culture.
I learned from my 94 classmates
that come from all over the world.
This girl who was sitting next to me
was from Guatemala
and the other guy was from Kenya.
And some people are from the US.
Some people are from kind of the areas
that I've never been to in the US.
It's the social experience
and building your network
and getting to know people
that have different business experience
is not something
I'm not against Jolt.
I think it's great.
I just think it's kind of a different proposition
and a different experience.
Meeting the case protagonist of CEOs
from leading companies
is not something that you can kind of do
without this social interactions.
So I think being part of clubs,
me wanting to transition
to health care.
Being part of the health care club.
Going to meet companies
in the Boston area.
I just feel like so many things
that I value about this experience
would've not happened
if I had gone for kind technical skills
at Jolt, which is awesome.
I'll probably do that in the future.
But it's just not,
I don't think it's a replacement
for one another.
So, what is the first step
for somebody who's now, I don't know,
they've had a few years experience
in the Israeli tech ecosystem
or other industries. And they say,
"Wow, I think I want to consider
going to business school.
Maybe Harvard or Stanford
are so far off.
Maybe I shouldn't even try."
What is the first step that they should do
in your mind to get that path started?
I think they should ask themself
why they want to go to business school.
And then they should look at their resume
and past experience and understand
if they have an interesting
and compelling story to tell
that would want to make someone
from Harvard or Stanford have them
and they'll be
like a powerful contribution.
I think that's, in the end,
that what makes or breaks
a candidate for business school.
And I personally believe that
while everybody has a story,
sometimes it's hard to uncover it
and hard to realize that perhaps
some experience that you've had
a few years ago, which you sort of overlooked,
to a lot of others
it's a fascinating story
and you can distill
a lot of lessons from it.
And I think that what you mentioned,
a lot of groups
that are helping candidates
write their application.
It's not that they're inventing
their life story;
it's that they're helping them
take these stories,
putting them on paper in a way
that people in the US can read
and really adopt emotionally.
And relate.
And relate because, at the end,
our cultures are so different
and while there's a lot of similarities,
there's so many differences.
And I think that these consulting groups
are doing a fantastic job
at helping international students come in and
sort of reframe their stories
to the American mindset.
And it's not just to English,
but to American language.
But Hadas, on that note,
we do have to end.
But thank you so much
for being so generous with your time.
I have one last question: three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Yes.
So I would use,
passionate, challenger, and doer.
Passionate, challenger, and doer.
I love it.
Hadas, toda raba.
Thank you very much.
Enjoy the second year of business school.
I hope that it's not gonna be
all online.
I hope that you go back to sitting
in that same spot
and hang that Israel flag back
in the back of the room.
And enjoy the rest of the quarantine.
I guess one more day.
Thank you, Michael.
And Shabbat shalom,
and good luck with your project.
Thank you very much.
Bye bye.